you go where
it's perfect
law school
you got into harvard law
what like it's harp
oh my gosh
it's been 20 years since reese
witherspoon became a household name you
remember l woods in legally blonde since
then she has also become a powerful
force in hollywood powerful is the word
there an investment firm recently poured
hundreds of millions of dollars into her
media company hello sunshine isn't that
the perfect name for a reese witherspoon
company yep the investment is
accelerating hello sunshine's mission to
tell diverse stories about women in all
mediums they produce hit series like
little fires everywhere and big little
lies and the morning show which just
kicked off its new season on apple reese
plays anchor bradley jackson in the
series she joined us from nashville to
talk all about it
let's talk about bradley jackson i love
this girl because she goes from someone
who's grateful to oh golly gosh i'm so
thankful to have this opportunity
to
uh when she's passed over for a job at
the evening news that she thought she
deserved to basically telling the boss
you
and by the way i'm gonna call in sick
for the next month
why was it important for you
i laughed at that too rhys because i'm
thinking if i had done that here at cbs
i'd be on times square going taxi please
does reese witherspoon need an assistant
i play nicely with others why was it
important for you that she demand more
well i think i was reading this
interesting thing about work and how we
the the three stages of work or i can't
wait to get there and then the next
stage is i'm so glad i'm here and then
the third stage is get me out of here
so i think you know she's so excited to
be in the rooms where it happens but she
demands respect and i think it's kind of
fun to pull behind the curtain and see
you know when people go into negotiation
tactics they can be ruthless even if
they're you know
new to the job last season steve
carell's character mitch kessler he was
ousted from the morning show because of
misconduct you all could have ended his
storyline there very easily but yet his
storyline continues why
i think it's an important time right now
that we're talking so much about cancel
culture you know and and we're
dismissing people and exiling people and
some rightly so
i think but there's this whole human
cost and what does it mean
to be publicly shamed
how do you put your life back together
your life isn't over you have to
reconstitute and rebuild and i think
it's really um
really thoughtful of our writers to
think about what is the extent of a
human experience that comes out of
cancer culture and also can we separate
the person from their work
and it definitely makes you think
yeah it does it raises some very
interesting questions let's talk about
julianna margolies
she's joining the cast this season
and boy does she take us on a ride she
shakes up bradley's world
she shakes up the tv network
well first first of all we were just so
excited to have her
because she just brings so much grace
and elegance and gravitas to everything
she does
my character is just in awe of her
because
it's like you know when when the person
you've looked up to all your life
suddenly is in your life and is your
mentor
it's very intoxicating
yeah that's a good line she really is in
your life isn't she bradley jackson
um yes she definitely gets into bradley
jackson's life and then as so this is
good so this is i'm not going to spoil
anything but as the season progresses
you start to wonder
is she being helpful to bradley or is
she maybe
trying to
mold bradley in an image that she wants
her to be
i'm wondering that's really good stuff
watching your show reese witherspoon
makes me think morning tv is ruthless is
it
i don't know gail you tell me
i refuse to answer on the grounds that
it may incriminate others
now let's talk about you reese
witherspoon outside of the morning show
you've made some real boss moves
recently with hello sunshine i love the
name of the company hello sunshine the
figure that's been thrown around about
the sale of your company is just under a
billion dollars can you say is that an
accurate figure
yeah that's accurate um
and it's so
wonderful because
you know when
a company that is
built on this mission
to highlight women and get women paid
for their work and have artists make
money off of their work when it does
well it really creates more opportunity
for similar companies to be emerging
into the marketplace and be valued at
the similar terms and when you started
the company years ago did you hope one
day that you could get it in a position
where it could be sold and you would
still be basically in charge of running
it
was that your intention
absolutely i wanted to grow it in a way
that has never been done inside of
hollywood and the media world because
you know women don't own a lot of things
we all know this and we don't talk about
money enough we don't talk about
investing enough we don't even talk
about
basic financial needs so i'm definitely
on a mission to make more women more
money my last question when you look
back over your career and your career's
still ongoing but let's just say your
career to date
what are you most proud of
gosh that's such a good question i'm
proud of this moment in my
career
because i've done a lot for myself but
i'm really proud of being able to open
the door for other people
because in any business you're in you
just want to leave it a better place
than the way you found it and when i
came into this business it wasn't
welcoming and it was really hard to be a
woman and it was almost impossible to be
a woman of color or lgbtq or differently
abled
and to be in a position where i'm able
to open the door for people who have
felt other for so long and say
now you get to tell your story in your
own words is enormously fulfilling and i
feel
excited every day to wake up and do that
for a living
we're excited for you too reese and also
very proud she said when she got the
check with all those zeros she's very
happy she said she cried she cried
because she thought about what it
represented and all the women that had
come before her that couldn't do what
she's doing now so she's enormously
proud and listen she really is just
getting started but when you think about
the morning show they had already been
shooting three weeks and then covet hit
so they had to go back and rewrite the
whole series the first season they had
to go back and rewrite because of me too
yeah so they they really do borrow from
the headlines and it's very very well
done did you really get a paper check
for 900 million probably like a direct
deposit right yeah i'm not sure about
that but i love the fact it started it
had a lot of zeros yeah doing big things